Авдіївка - це Україна, написано на в'їзді в місто.
Машини зустрічає це промовисте опудало.
Попри те, що прифронтові містечка майже вщент зруйновані,
тут досі залишаються тисячі цивільних.
Ці поліцейські намагаються змусити місцевих залишити місто.
Геннадій і Дмитро працюють в евакуаційному підрозділі
поліції "Білі ангели".
Залишатися дуже небезпечно.
Працює один магазин, де можна придбати хліб.
Сам похід до магазину або за водою, або за ліками,
або в лікарню - це квест. Пройдеш-не пройдеш.
Виживеш-не виживеш. Можна потрапити під обстріл
й або отримати поранення, або загинути.
Сьогодні вранці з ними приїхав колега, щоб попрощатися
з власною мамою. Чотири дні тому вона загинула внаслідок вибуху,
коли йшла на роботу на місцевий коксохімічний завод.
До війни в Авдіївці мешкали понад 32 тисячі людей.
Нині на це зруйноване місто безперебійно
падають російські бомби.
Близько 2000 людей досі залишаються в Авдіївці.
Це імпровізований "пункт незламності" для них.
Тут є чай, струм і - з ким поговорити.
Це моя батьківщина. Я тут народилася,
я тут все життя прожила. Тут мої батьки у землі лежать.
Я не хочу кидати свій дім. Праця двох поколінь просто знищена.
Мені дуже шкода, але це сильніше за мене.
Я не можу поїхати.
Геннадій та Дмитро приїхали по конкретну сімейну пару.
Донька цього чоловіка попросила поліцейських вивезти їх з міста.
Нині вони живуть у підвалі.
Ваша донька надіслала нам відеозапис.
Просила, щоб ви переглянули його.
Тато, привіт. Так тривати більше не може.
Я не можу допустити, щоб мій рідний батько жив у таких умовах.
Богом молю! Дуже сподіваюся і чекаю на тебе.
Цілую й обіймаю.
- Ваша донька? Миколайовичу, готові виїхати?
- Ні. - Чому? Готові ж вас прихистити. Донька ж прийме вас.
- Не готовий. - Чому? Коли будете готові? Скажіть.
- Коли все закінчиться.
Страх і відчуття приреченості - те, що їх стримує.
Від долі не втечеш. Якщо тобі судилося від цього загинути,
ти загинеш. Якщо ні, то ні. Я, наприклад, боюся дороги.
Мені здається, що в дорозі зі мною щось трапиться.
Геннадій і Дмитро не можуть примусити людей піти.
Через російську пропаганду дехто з них боїться української влади.
Вмовляємо, даємо час на роздуми людям.
Ми їх вивозимо на броньованому автомобілі до Покровська,
де їх приймуть волонтери, оформлять пенсію,
оформлять допомогу переселенцям, і все в них буде добре…
Ми змушені припинити зйомку… і шукати сховище.
Як тільки стало безпечно, ми вирушили туди,
куди влучила бомба.
Ми якраз закінчували зйомку з тією жінкою в підвалі.
Буквально за кілька сотень метрів ми почули потужний вибух.
І ось наслідки, як ви бачите.
Буквально кілька хвилин тому сюди влучила ракета
і рознесла все це місце.
Таке тут, в Авдіївці, повсякденне життя…
Бомба розтрощила міський ринок.
Ця жінка приходила сюди продавати господарські товари.
Вона не постраждала, але в сильному шоці.
Авдіївка була прифронтовим містом задовго до повномасштабного
російського вторгнення. Проросійські сепаратисти
протягом короткого періоду контролювали цю територію
в 2014 році, а потім Україна повернула її.
Тепер росіяни знову намагаються завоювати місто.
За годину їзди звідси - Часів Яр неподалік Бахмута.
Вважається, що тут залишилося менше десяти відсотків людей.
Тут ми зустрічаємо пана Олега.
Йому 74 роки, він працював економістом.
Зараз за розбитими вікнами вирощує цибулю.
Це мій брат картини малював. Натуральні.
Він рукою малював. Він у Москві навчався в художньому інституті.
Тут я живу, тут моя спальня. Я тут жив.
Було затишно, світло було, опалення було.
Зараз нічого цього немає, звичайно.
8 лютого ракета прилетіла у двір.
Пан Олег сподівається на допомогу волонтерів.
Попри обстріли і руїни він залишається тут.
Не хочеться нікуди їхати. Я тут народився,
довго прожив, тут мої батьки були.
Я не хочу їхати від їхніх могил. Краще помру, тут буду,
поховають.
Не бійтеся... Це від нас стріляють…
Пенсіонер - один з тих мешканців Авдіївки,
хто все ще ностальгує за радянськими часами.
Він показує нам радянський військовий квиток
- 43-річної давнини. І повторює наративи російської пропаганди.
Мені шкода і тих дурнів, і цих. Це один народ.
Це ті самі люди, розумієте. Всі вони були в Радянському Союзі,
всі служили в радянській армії колись.
А зараз погляди розділилися.
Начальство десь неправильно зробило,
що зіштовхнули один народ. Не треба було цього робити, розумієте.
Треба було домовлятися.
Це поширена думка в тутешніх містах.
Є й ті, хто не просто ностальгує за Радянським Союзом,
а навіть чекає, коли прийдуть росіяни.
Запитуємо про це поліцейського Геннадія.
На жаль, є такі випадки. Є. Чекають так званого "русского міра".
Можливо, і зливають інформацію про розташування Збройних сил України.
Є такі випадки, коли СБУ затримувала таких людей.
Є у місцевих мешканців родичі, які воюють на тому боці…
Офіцери "Білих ангелів" пропонують людям можливість
вибратися з міста. Але тут уже майже не залишилося тих,
хто ще хоче цим скористатися.